Speaker 1: All right, I got a bunch of emails
from folks over the last 24 hours about this
new book coming out from the very short lived
White House press secretary Stephanie Grisham,
who worked for Donald Trump for a little bit. She
has written a new book and some of the allegations
in the book are just absolutely crazy. We're
going to talk about them. Each is crazier
than the last or the previous or whatever
sort of phraseology you want to use. Let's
start with this first one about Donald Trump
having what's being described as a surgical
procedure. I'm going to talk about this in a
second. And opting not to receive anesthesia
because if he had received anesthesia, he would
have had to temporarily turn over presidential
powers to the vice president, Mike Pence. This
happened when George W. Bush had I believe it
was also a colonoscopy back during his
presidency and Dick Cheney was briefly,
temporarily given presidential power. So
the story is Trump skipped anesthesia for
a previously unreported procedure at Walter
Reed to avoid giving Penn's temporary power.
The details are that Trump skipped anesthesia
for a previously unreported colonoscopy in 2019
so he wouldn't have to temporarily relinquish
presidential powers. This is according to a
new book called I'll Take Your Questions Now.
Stephanie Grisham wrote it, former White House
press secretary and chief of staff to Melania
Trump. She said in the book that this was for
a regular colonoscopy. Now, let's talk about
that a little bit. The initial story was, wow,
Trump's pretty alpha. I mean, he's saying do the
opper do the surgery without anesthesia. That that
is wild. Then it came out. It's a colonoscopy. So
you might be asking is, is it accurate to say that
it is surgery? Is a colonoscopy really surgery?
It is classified as a minor surgical procedure.
Sometimes they're just taking a look.
Sometimes if there is a polyp or something,
then they are cutting something out and then it's,
you know, more more clearly a surgical procedure.
It is generally done with anesthesia. Often it's
like a deep sedation. You're not like out like I
was for my famous appendectomy. But you are you
are sedated. But it is one of the things that
that is done without anesthesia. And some say
that it is safer without a general sedation.
I you know, I'm not a medical expert. I don't
know exactly that. But it's the patient's choice.
And sometimes patients don't realize they have
that choice. But it is not inaccurate to call
it a surgery in the sense that that is how it is
classified. So the article goes on to say, Trump
puzzled reporters with a mysterious unscheduled
November 20 19 visit to Walter Reed. You might
remember this is that infamous why did he go to
Walter Reed? And added to the confusion by saying
it was part of his routine annual physical for
2020. Remember, he said, I was just hanging out
and I thought I'd go and get get a jump in twenty
nineteen on my twenty twenty physical. That was
a lie. We believed it to be a lie at the time and
it was, and it was for a colonoscopy. But the big
news is that he, according to Stephanie Grisham,
opted not to receive the general anesthesia
in order to maintain presidential
power and not have to relinquish it
to Vice President Mike Pence. Grisham wrote in
the book, Trump could have used the procedure
to spread awareness and educate Americans about
the importance of colonoscopy. But as with covid,
he was too wrapped up in his own ego and his
own delusions about invincibility and he, quote,
didn't want to be the butt of a joke. How immature
do you have to be as a 70 plus year old man? So,
first of all, there's the the the desire to
keep power. And maybe Trump was imagining
if Pence were president and I was the
VP, I would be using this opportunity
to try to somehow seize the power of the
presidency when the president is being
sedated for a colonoscopy. So maybe Trump's
idea of I don't want to give it up to Pence
was rooted in if I were pence, I'd be trying to
seize power. We don't know. But that certainly
tracks with Donald Trump. But then the other part
of this is, you know, the idea that you're going
to be laughed at because you've got a colonoscopy
in your 70s rather than, hey, you know what?
This is a great opportunity to talk about the
importance of routine screenings and colonoscopy
being a part of that. But no, that's not the way
that Trump functions. So it all tracks here. And
for me, the bigger story is with this Stephanie
Grisham book. And we're going to get in a moment
to more of what? She writes in the book,
This is another person, Stephanie Grisham,
who was in Trump's inner circle, had
a front row seat to what was going on,
who saw the reckless, dangerous and petty
behavior that Donald Trump was engaged in,
did nothing, said nothing at the time,
and later is speaking out about it. Now,
when there's an opportunity to make money from
it, from writing a book, that should come as no
surprise either because Trump was surrounded by
these people. But it is yet another despicable
action by one of these folks. Let's now talk about
the next story from Stephanie Grissom's new book